what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about the emotional roller coaster that
is the current
attack on titan story and i will also be
talking about what is perhaps
the most tragic death in the entire
series
so far and that is saying a lot for
attack on titan
this latest major death was
heartbreaking in so many ways
and yet it was also powerful and in some
ways even beautiful
i know that might sound crazy but stay
tuned and i will talk about it all
right here in this video if you enjoyed
the attack on titan content on the
channel and you want us to keep it going
please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime pro or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then
selecting the option that says all it's
kind of annoying but if you don't do
that
you're gonna miss a lot of our videos
even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain attack on titan manga spoilers
i'm talking about the very latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the latest installment
of the story begins as the anti-aaron
alliance arrives in odiha
the city that was mentioned in previous
chapters as the place from which the
airplane is going to take
off by the time that the alliance's ship
arrives odiha
is already deserted the citizens have
all fled the rumbling
and they have taken their boats and all
other forms of transportation with them
this actually makes it easier for the
allies to sneak
into the city and perform the necessary
maintenance on the airplane
as the airplane is loaded up into a
hangar and prepared for maintenance
armin realizes that the explosives which
the jaegers were going to use to destroy
the plane can now be used
on aaron's titan instead so armin
instructs reiner and the others to pack
the explosives
into the airplane and you better believe
that these explosives are going to come
into play again
at some point in the future meanwhile
falco is
absolutely devastated to learn that
commander mcgath and his entire family
in liberio
are already dead falco wasn't fully
aware of what was happening because his
first titan transformation left him
unconscious and confused
but now that he is back to his senses he
is finally forced to face the
terrible reality of the situation pique
explains that most of the continent of
marlei
has already been engulfed by the
rumbling and when a confused and anxious
falco asks what they are supposed to do
now
the usually calm and collected peak
admits that she doesn't know
and she seems to be visibly agitated it
really is kind of strange to see peak
like this
but her behavior and the behavior of
falco gabby and the others really
underscores the severity of the current
situation
the attack on titan's story is unfolding
before our
eyes but this is no longer the same
story that it was before
a literal global apocalypse is happening
as we speak
i mean in attack on titan not in the
real world hopefully
and this is something that all of the
characters are forced to constantly
grapple with
as they do their best to keep moving
forward in that
crazy world elsewhere mikasa encourages
annie to get some practice with the new
vertical maneuvering gear
but any response that there is no point
because
she is done annie isn't interested in
trying to save humanity
and even though she feels bad for
everyone else who is desperately trying
to defeat aaron and save their
homeland annie has basically given up
she doesn't really have any hope that
the alliance will succeed
in defeating aaron and since she no
longer has anyone left to fight for now
that her father
is almost certainly dead annie just
wants to live out her final moments
in peace she is sick of war and fighting
and she is sick of all the death and
destruction
she just wants a moment of peace as
annie throws a shy glance at armin
mikasa suddenly realizes that
annie loves armin mikasa even asks her
when this started but annie acts like
she doesn't understand
so mikasa was like yeah sure okay oh
by the way harmon is coming with us on
the airplane
mikasa is loki telling annie that armin
will be risking his life with the rest
of them as they try to stop aaron
so if annie really wants to stay behind
that's cool
but if she does she might never see
armin again
there is actually a lot of interesting
subtext going on in this conversation
between mikasa and
annie not to be outdone in terms of
romantic awkwardness
annie then outright asks mikasa if she
is going to kill aaron
in order to save humanity but mikasa
confirms that she is
not going to kill aaron mikasa still
believes that the real
aaron is somewhere in there she just
needs to bring him back
essentially mikasa cannot accept that
aaron is truly evil
she believes that he just lost his
humanity under the pressure of these
extreme circumstances but mikasa seems
to think that she can still bring him
back to his old self if only she can get
through to him she might have a point
but then again mikasa isn't necessarily
aware of all the things that aaron has
been doing and planning for all of these
years
and mikasa doesn't know about all the
information that aaron had gained from
future memories
information which he had used to make
this plan
a reality i know i've said this before
but aaron really crossed the line when
he slaughtered
all those innocent civilians in the
previous chapter
and so i really doubt that he can never
go back to his old self
at this point but we'll have to wait and
see as mikasa walks away
annie asks her how come she isn't
wearing her red scarf
mikasa confirms that she's not wearing
it right now but
she still has it with her and in this
moment mikasa scarf truly embodies
mikasa's ongoing hope that she can bring
aaron back the scarf which is not
visible now
but will likely come back represents
mikasa's hope
in aaron she is hoping that she can
replace this ruthless man who decided to
destroy the entire world
with the real errand that she's known
from her childhood
but here's the real question is the real
aaron the kind good-natured and brash
boy
from mikasa's childhood or has the real
aaron always been the man who initiated
the rumbling
this is something that i'm personally
very interested in finding out
was aaron always destined to do what he
has just done
or did he have control of his own fate
and could he still
change his mind as all of this is
happening levi despite being severely
injured
insists that he wants to take part in
the fight
and so along with arm and peak hanji and
the others
levi interrogates yelena about what
exactly aaron is planning to do
with the rumbling the allies need to
figure out which direction
aaron himself is planning to take if
they can hope to get a chance to
overtake him using the airplane and that
is when we finally learn
more about aaron's master plan we see a
flashback to the time where aaron was
still pretending to go along with zeke's
euthanasia plan
and both yell and i and flock are in the
room as they discuss their plans
after the rumbling it seems that the
initial plan that zeke approved of was
to activate the rumbling
but at a limited scale so instead of all
of the wall titans being activated
only a few hundred would be activated
and used to wipe out key military
targets and infrastructure on the
continent of marley
the idea was to take out the massive
enemy fleet which was gathering near
parodies
and then to take out another key target
which is a fortress
in the south of marley this fortress is
known for researching
flying boats or airplanes and these
airplanes could potentially pose a
serious threat to parodies
and to aaron's titan this limited
rumbling was necessary
for zeke's plan because although he
wanted to eliminate the aldian
population by making them all sterile
he didn't want to kill them all off
immediately
zeke wanted the aldians who are alive
today to be able to live out their lives
in peace
and zeke believed that by taking out the
enemy fleets and also other key targets
such as military bases
the partial rumbling would give paradise
several decades of peace before the
other countries could fully recover
and attack again basically zeke was just
trying to buy time for the current
generation of aldians to live out their
lives peacefully
and then after they died no more aldians
would be born to replace them
and the world would no longer need to
hate or target aldians
obviously things did not turn out the
way that zeke and yelena had expected
them to
instead of a partial rumbling aaron went
all out
and instead of destroying just some key
military targets in marley
he is planning to destroy everything but
with that said
yelena still believes that aaron's next
target
is going to be fort salta the military
base in the south of marley where the
airplane research is being conducted
since new airplane technology could
theoretically pose a threat to aaron's
titan
his first instinct will be to eliminate
that threat as soon as possible
so yelena finally proves to be useful
for once because she helps to identify
aaron's likely next target which will
likely prove crucial for the alliance
since they can't fly the airplane
aimlessly until they find aaron
their fuel capacity is limited so they
do need to have some idea of where
aaron is actually heading but yelena
then ruins this almost immediately
as she proceeds to simp for zeke yet
again and she starts talking about how
his plan was better and less deadly than
aaron's
hanji admits that aaron's solution
wasn't a good one but come on let's face
it neither was zeke's
the man wanted to stand by and allow his
entire race of people to go extinct
because of the sins of their ancestors
which they committed hundreds of years
ago
we can definitely say that what aaron is
doing isn't just
but what zeke was planning to do wasn't
just either
even though pique seems very shaken and
traumatized by everything that happened
she decides that she will still go and
fight but she tells kiyomi to lock gabby
and falco
inside their rooms on the ship and not
to let them out
until the airplane takes off peak
believes that gabby and falco will be
safer on the ship than on the airplane
and so she wants them to stay behind
even the injured levi says that he is
going to fight
and that two fingers is all he needs to
wield his weapon
what an absolute badass mad lad
chad levi is but of course we always
knew that levi would fight
under no circumstances would this man
stay behind
but since annie is staying behind the
allies tell her to take care of gabby
and falco
annie then has a deeply emotional moment
with reiner in which reiner apologizes
for everything that he had put her
and bertolt through by insisting that
they continue their mission to
infiltrate parodies
all those years ago reiner has
definitely matured as a character
and he has finally come to understand
the full consequences of his actions
honestly reiner has come so far from
that ideologically brainwashed kid who
naively thought that if he could only
kill the devils on parodies
then he would finally be accepted by his
father and by marlene society and his
life would be perfect
reiner has done some unforgivable things
in his life
but i definitely appreciate how his
character has evolved over the course of
the story
armin clearly has some mixed feelings
about annie deciding to stay behind
but he wants her to be able to be
herself and make her own decisions
annie has lived her entire life obeying
the orders of others
even when she herself didn't believe in
those orders
so now she should finally get the chance
to follow her
own path i have to say that i'm pretty
surprised to see annie staying out of
the fight
after finally emerging from the crystal
after all those years
but who knows maybe this is just a psych
out by isayama and annie will end up
getting drawn into the fight eventually
only time will tell then in a weird but
kind of classic hanji moment she asks
pique to let her ride
on the back of her titan and peek is
like uh
no dude what's with your creepy titan
fetish
and levi then teases hanji about yet
another titan
failing to return her love hanji
proceeds to ask levi
a very poignant question she asks him if
he thinks that all their dead comrades
are watching them
and she asks if they will be able to
stand tall among their dead comrades
when the time comes levi tells hanji not
to start talking like
him referring of course to the one and
only captain erwin
but just as the allies make all the
necessary preparations
and just as the airplane is almost ready
for takeoff freaking flock
shows up yet again he didn't die back on
parodies
just as i suspected since we never
actually saw his body
and it turns out that he had somehow
held onto the ship
all the way to odiha despite being
injured flock manages to crawl his way
inside the airplane hangar and he uses
his gun to shoot up the airplane and of
course he does this in an attempt to
stop the plane from being able to take
off as everyone scrambles to dodge the
bullets
mikasa uses the steel hook on her
vertical maneuvering gear to pierce
flock's throat as flock lays there dying
oyan component the engineers realized
that he has managed to shoot holes
through the airplane's fuel tank just
when the plane was finally prepared to
take off
it now has holes in the fuel tank which
means that it won't be able to take off
after all
not unless it is fixed immediately the
engineers will need an hour to weld
the holes shut but that's more time than
they actually have
because in that very moment the tools on
the table begin to rattle
it is as if an earthquake is hitting the
hangar but in reality
it is the rumbling the titans are
almost here as the rumbling descends
upon odiha
the engineers struggle to fix the
airplane and to get it
airborne with his final breath flock
warns his comrades yet again
that stopping aaron would bring about
the end of everyone on parodies
their devil aaron is their
only hope i didn't think about this
while writing the script but now that
i'm recording i remember that i made an
entire video
talking about how aaron might actually
be the earth devil
that historia learned about in the story
books about emir fritz
now that we know everything about
aaron's future memories and how he
entices emir fritz to join him and
create this entire rumbling
that theory is starting to make even
more sense
to be fair it wasn't the earth devil who
initially gave emir fritz the titan
powers
as we originally thought but it was
aaron who enticed emir fritz
to launch the rumbling along with him
anyway
in that moment the divine king emperor
flock forster
dies clearly this is the single most
tragic death in all of attack on titan
so far now you know what i meant
in the introduction of the video i mean
it's hard to even talk right now i need
some time to grieve
please everyone f's in the chat for our
boy
flock he will definitely be missed by
someone
i guess hanji is well aware that flock
has a point
and she knows that some sort of real
lasting peace between the nations
seems impossible right now and that is
of course why aaron decided to do what
he is doing now
but hanji still has hope that one day
things could change
she refuses to give up and she refuses
to stand by as aaron destroys the entire
world
upon realizing that the titans are
almost there gabby and falco
tried to escape their room and help but
annie refuses to let them out
and kilmi shovels coal into the ship's
engine
in order to get it moving annie carries
out her duty
and protects gabby and falco as promised
and the steam ship successfully departs
and leaves odiha behind back on land
the allies know that they don't have
enough time to get the plane airborned
before the titans arrive
someone will need to stay behind and
slow the titans down
at the cost of their own life armin
volunteers to do it
since being suicidal is kind of his
thing now and then reiner volunteers
saying that they need armin in order to
stop aaron but in the end
hanji decides that she will be the one
to make the ultimate sacrifice
they can't afford to lose anyone who is
a shifter their powers are too valuable
so hanji promotes armin to the 15th
commander of the survey corps and
she takes the responsibility for slowing
down the titans
upon herself i find it kind of crazy
that hanji says that there is no one
more suited for the duty of being
commander than armin
especially with how armin has been
acting lately like did we forget that he
almost
fed himself to connie's mother just a
few chapters ago
but hey he's a good strategist so i
guess that's why he's indispensable
whatever
let's just go with it hanji then says
goodbye to everyone and as she walks
away she comes
face to face with levi hanji tells levi
to let her go
since it's finally her turn to make the
ultimate sacrifice
and she wants to look as cool as
possible as she does this
one final act unclearly emotional levi
grabs hanji's caller and says
sageo and hanji actually laughs because
she never heard him say those words
before
man this was truly an emotional moment
especially when we think back to that
time that levi and hanji spent in the
woods
back then as hanji was nursing levi back
to health after zeke's explosion
for a moment she considered just staying
alone in the woods with levi forever
but of course she couldn't do that they
couldn't just sit by and do nothing as
the entire world burned
and now they must face the consequences
of that
choice the chapter ends with hanji
zooming off to face the colossal titans
head on
and even as she prepares to engage in
the final battle of her life
hanji can't help but admire the wall
titans in all of their grotesque
glory hanji stays true to herself and
her quirky personality
until the very end she bravely takes
down
several titans who had been closest to
the city and this buys the allies just
enough time to fix the plane
and take off in the last possible moment
the wall titans are so hot that just
being close to them
is making hanji's clothes and entire
body catch on fire but
even so she continues to fight on
fiercely she keeps attacking and slicing
at the nape of the titans
even as her own body literally burns
and then as both the ship and the
airplane take off
in the nick of time hanji's body is
consumed by flames
and eventually it is crushed beneath the
feet of the titans
oh obviously this is a really sad and
emotional moment for all of us
long time fans of attack on titan hanji
has been such a pivotal character
and an extremely likable character for
most of the story she was funny
smart a little crazy and she played a
key role in keeping the scouts together
through all the pain and suffering that
they went through after the death of
irwin but here's the interesting
thing unlike the vast majority of deaths
in attack on titan
hanji's death is not portrayed in a
graphically violent or gruesome way
we see her corpse only from a bird's eye
view and from a great distance
and then we see her wake up her body
fully
intact she is suddenly surrounded by all
her former comrades from the survey
corps who lost their lives in the past
including erwin
sasha shadis and more as the airplane
flies away
the survey corps members help hanji to
her feet
and she immediately begins to complain
to irwin about all the trouble he caused
her by naming her commander
and she also complains about aaron being
an idiot and
that is where this tragic and yet
powerful chapter
ends the final images that we see of
hanji
are not images of her brutally mutilated
corpse they are
images of her joining her comrades in
the afterlife
and she looks normal as if she never
even went through that final battle
against the titans whether you think
that this afterlife is just symbolic or
whether you believe that it is real
i think that hanji's death shows just
how much isayama respected her character
he wanted us to remember hanji the way
that she was in life
and he wanted us to think of her as a
faithful survey corps member who did her
duty
and then joined her comrades in a
peaceful afterlife
isa emma could easily have made it so
that the last time we saw hanji she was
just a charred
and flattened corpse and certainly in
attack on titan
seeing such gruesome images is nothing
new but
islama didn't do that and i believe that
this was very much
intentional he wanted to pay a special
kind of respect
to this memorable and beloved character
and i think he succeeded
as attack on titan fans we are almost
desensitized to the gory graphic and
brutal deaths of the past
so the fact that hanji's death was
portrayed differently makes it more
memorable
hanji's death was of course tragic but
it was also powerful
and even beautiful in its own way
despite all the death that we have
witnessed in attack on titan
you can never really get used to such an
important character dying
but i think that in this moment we can
all come together to honor
hanji's life courage and sacrifice
and after we pay our respects we have to
ask ourselves
what happens next the allies now have a
rough idea
of where aaron is going which makes it
more likely that they will in fact
intercept him but what happens then will
it be a battle to the death
will mikasa somehow succeed in getting
through to aaron
when will the famous red scarf make its
appearance
so many lingering questions what do you
guys think will happen next and who else
is going to die
before the story ends what do you think
about annie gabby and falco staying
behind
is their story over or are they still
going to end up getting involved in the
final battle somehow
let me know down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more attack on titan content on
the channel please leave a like to let
me know it really does help
and if you're new to anime pro or you
just haven't subscribed yet please make
this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
if you don't go through the trouble of
hitting the bell and selecting the
option that says
all you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works i wanna give
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible a very special thank
you to
alpha sigma a disciple of lord twego
himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including ingrata alone adam the world
acquired respect
pate heffa jonathan king brandon aviles
papa smurf emperor otaku thomas jones
kid mano
and admirath finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson king
zeldris anatoly kazotsky angel cruz
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
jessica califond hinokai and water
bonnie parks rothwing de ora florian
joni garcia steelers deadly saint and
stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you